i got to ask you about the sneakers
because i went in to say hi to you
backstage yeah
they're unusual those are converse
sneakers but you seem to have made them
uh
had them custom made for you i
customized them uh myself
uh and i got a special uh you can if you
go online
you can uh can everyone see what that
says
your sneakers to say whatever you want
so i went
i went for butthole uh i noticed that
i'm ashamed i noticed that but i did and
you you put a lot of effort into it i
did it was hard to do because they have
a filter you go online you could just
design your own sneakers and it says
like do you want to write a special word
on the back
and obviously yes i do and obviously
i want it to be as disgusting and
juvenile as possible so
uh you kind of have to trick the filter
but converse has a pretty lenient filter
because butthole
probably my first try and uh that made
it through there
yeah they have a pretty lax system over
there yeah at reebok you can't get away
with butthole
yeah reebok i had to do bumhole
you have a frustrating life i do it's
pretty tough
trying to circumvent sneaker company
censorship system
now you're in atlanta final four in
uh are you into the ncaa tournament do
you get as excited about as everyone
else
uh no not at all
i i wish i did people seem to love it so
much
i i always watch people watch sports and
i'm like man i wish i cared where the
ball went as much as you guys do
like i just don't i try to care so
he almost got the ball in the thing and
i just don't care i don't
i don't care where the ball goes so uh
what do you do here when you don't like
sports
that's a good question what do you do if
you're like in atlanta and you don't
like sports
uh i heard actually that you go to strip
clubs
reaction alone i think you hit the right
answer which is great
but keep in mind these people booed an
orange exactly
i hate oranges too so great that's good
screw citrus but uh but yeah uh i hear
the strip clubs here are great because
uh i don't know i just heard that i
don't know that's the circles i run in
do you go i mean have you been going to
strip clubs for a long time are you
someone that attends i
kind of enjoy uh yeah i go to some strip
clubs every once in a while
uh it's nice uh there's naked women
there
they uh they pretend to like you which
is great
uh it's nice it's funny because like
when you're just you know everyone the
strip you go to the strip club and they
pretend to like you and if you're a guy
you convince yourself like this stripper
likes me like this is crazy
uh but when you're like an actor you do
that to yourself even more you're like
she doesn't like these other guys she
really likes me
because i'm an actor but then but then
uh once she starts giving you the lap
dance you realize she uses like the same
stock lines on everybody because she'll
be like oh your body's so good
and i'm like no it's not i just know
that's
these are not the compliments that work
for me if she's like oh you take care of
your family financially i'd be like yeah
i do
she knows me she does like me for me
yeah
those are the things i wish they should
say that i should say that should fit
your personality exactly yeah you seem
very considerate to those
around you you're a good dog owner
[Laughter]
do you uh okay uh here's a question for
you have you ever been in a strip club
with someone who
you were convinced that strippers really
did like yeah i uh
i went to a strip club with matt dillon
once um
the actor matt the actor matt dillon and
they really did like him
like it was i saw the look on their
faces i was like oh that's the look when
a stripper really likes you that's not
the look i've ever gotten from a
stripper to me it's always like
have you uh have you ever gone to
amsterdam to the to the red light
district i have gone to amsterdam yeah
this is turning more into a police
interrogation exactly yeah it was uh
but i was with a guy that night so uh no
i went there
i i went there when i was 18 uh years
old
and uh it was kind of scary actually
because like you go to the red light
district and all the girls are like
behind the glass doors and they're just
kind of presenting themselves
like that in sexy ways that would be my
pose if i was one of them
uh that looks like you're han solo
frozen
in the carbonite mode that's that's
that's the hooker i would get but
she's in the star wars
get me the carbonite